it's sexy Monday a lot of you been
asking about like theme songs and that
sort of thing I I just I don't know I
don't know let's build this together
shall we but we're in a very like lucid
state right now and I want to feel like
we are constructing this thing together
because this is ultimately for us this
is our little weird world bubble Sims
place where there's a draught neck with
a scarf around it oh giraffe you look
like a film critic now you look like a
real film critic one of my favorite
things to do is stream-of-consciousness
videos where I just talk nonsense at you
are you better for it afterwards
probably not but at least it kept you
procrastinating on that thing that
probably would have made you better and
basically that is the logline of the
Internet the Internet's that thing that
lets you procrastinate on that other
thing that would have made you a better
person John Green write the book and
then make it into a movie what are we
talking about today nothing and
everything what's been happening let's
talk about the world what did I do
what have I done with my life to deep
get out of there
get back into the shallow end of the
pool I didn't get my roots done should I
get bangs again this video is making you
a better person what if I cut my hair
like that I'd be like Alexis on the Real
Housewives of Orange County I swear this
video is making you a better person
oh my god now you're all in fried iron
what's going on with you guys how are
you
the sports did the sports later today I
am going over to Hannah Hart's place
because Hannah Hart is a die-hard 49ers
fan and they were playing the Seattle
Seahawks and she is gonna lose her mind
about it and so today I am by
association a 49ers fan today as in
yesterday today when you're watching
this the sporting event will have
happened so here are
reactions to it yeah we'll find out
which one is more accurate I had chicken
wings for the first time last week
and I almost felt religion I love a lump
lump lump lump lump oh yeah hey guys
it's tax season you're all teenagers
that doesn't mean anything to you but to
someone like me it is Earl I want to
make you sweat sweat till you cannot
sweat no more that would mean you are
dead
looks like I'm but I know feels like a
butt all right look I bought these shoes
in a moment of panic and their sneakers
with heels inside of them and I just
sometimes we all try to be things that
we are not I love Tyler Oakley I said it
and I said it and guess what I said it
what do you call a baguette that has
posed for a Victoria's Secret a role
model here's something I can't get out
my head hold on let me get it give me 20
minutes to get this set up for you talk
amongst yourselves
the topic is fertilizer why don't they
call it turtle Iser
just a bunch of Cinnabon sounds like
he's saying Cinnabon
the delicious delicious dessert pastry
chain I know I can't hear the song any
other way so it's ruined so just needed
to tell you because the Internet is for
sharing
this makes me look like I know about
music I don't know go and do a goose
interview look come here oh yeah and
then what
right and then what else happened what
else yeah and then she said what Wow
that is this show racist I agree I know
it's a letdown because you thought that
she had bigger values than that yeah and
then yeah Wow
so you're never going back there again
you can't that would help I know and you
got a save face